outra coisa interessante lá é quando
você aprende uma palavra em espanhol meu
amigo você aprende uma palavra em
espanhol pronto acabou e o turístico
quando você alguém falar com você e você
for dizer obrigado você diz Gracias aí
pronto eu procurava as pessoas para
falar Gracias Ola senhor tudo bem Você
sabe me dizer onde a rua que fica bem
aqui para de trás sim Gracias Olá moça
tudo bem Queria um pão Gracias Sim sim
eu também tinha um tia lá no Brasil o
nome dela sabe como é tia Gracias Ai meu
Deus o piada sem Graças lá em Machu
pichu é alto para né então às
vezes dá enjoo nas pessoas você chega no
aeroporto já tem propaganda de remédio
para enjoo e eu pô vou comprar esse
remédio para enjoo para não chegar lá em
matupit e ficar passando vergonha lá aí
eu fui na farmácia e e lá no peru e no
Chile tem pessoas que sabem que você é
brasileiro então eles falam espanhol
devagar que aí você entende o espanhol
aí você aí que você se sente no Rebelde
mesmo só que tem gente que não tá nem aí
pr você não falei Moça por favor um
remédio para enjoo aí ela não compreendo
não compreendo não não não não
compreendo aí eu olhei PR ela eu fiz
assim ó moça um remédio pra aí ela por
cá ou por cá Senhor